well I don't think there's any doubt
about that I think he's I mean he's a
very very strong player in in short time
controls as mentioned he has more
experience than me with this particular
time control and he's also tremendous
chess players so yeah it's not gonna be
easy yeah so Peter actually is one of
the few players here who I think has a
lot of experience in Fischer random I
think out of all the players here I
would say myself LaVon and Peter or the
three players who actually have the most
experience in match formats Peter played
in Germany in the minds of that many
years ago I think he played against uh I
think he played a match against LaVon I
think he might have also played against
like oh I'm not not sure but he has a
lot of experience so certainly I think
playing against him will be he won't be
inexperienced so it's gonna be a fight
from the get-go and Peter can be very
creative but he's also very good at
calculating I played this game to have
fun and I don't associate complete
symmetry for 10 moves with fun
necessarily so
I will have to balance trying to be
competitive in the match with this
desire to you know experiment and create
something I should try you know
inventing something and again somebody
of Jakara strength and experience and
and also you know tactical acumen if I
don't train this in it might it might
lead to trouble I have a feeling it
might not it might not work all that
well but we'll see I think that he's
he's he's gonna present but he's gonna
be it's gonna be quite an interesting
match and I'm just looking forward to
playing
you
you